[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends welcome to the
program I'd like to know
this is uh the sequence unsealed some TV
question and answer program that we have
each week
and you send us your questions we do the
research and then do our best to try and
answer the questions that you sent us
let me give you the address where you
can send questions uh you'll see it on
the screen TV at some tv.org once again
TV at some tv.org we'd be delighted to
get your questions of course some
questions we cannot answer because they
involve Mysteries or perhaps we're not
able to find an answer but insofar as
possible we'll do the research and we'll
try to answer your question I have with
me Pastor David Salazar who was in
charge of the Spanish I'd like to know
as well as all of our Spanish broadcasts
and it's always good to work with you
Pastor Salazar thank you Pastor Roy is a
blessing for me to also be part of this
program we're glad you're here thank you
indeed and of course we should never try
to answer questions without prayer and
so we want to ask Pastor Salazar to
please play please pray that the Lord
will be with us amen let's pray heavenly
father as we come before you we humbly
seek your Holy Spirit to come into our
minds into our hearts to lead us into
all truth and to help us to answer the
questions according to your will and
according to your word we thank you for
being with us and we pray that the
program will be a blessing to those that
are watching we pray this in Jesus name
amen amen
okay the first question is somewhat
complicated I'm going to work our way
through it and then see if we can find
an answer it's coming from Washington
State
North West from here actually directly
north that's right okay
could you please iron out something for
me
in a recent episode you answered a
question stating that the false prophet
and the Beast were symbolic
Esther Bohr proceeded further to state
that beasts in the Bible represent
kingdoms or nations
and then he puts in parentheses which I
agree with but when studying this
question further I was pondering on the
fact that the beast in Revelation 13
Verse 18 is clearly represented as a man
according to the verse
by the way the false prophet is also a
beast
the false prophet is the same as the
Beast that rises from the earth correct
so so it's not the false prophet it's
not a single individual it's a beast
it's a beast okay we continue uh then he
quotes Revelation 13 Verse 18 where it
says here's wisdom let him that hath
understanding count the number of the
Beast for it is the number of amen and
his number is 606 three score and six
um and then he continues and also that
the verses in Revelation 19 20 refers to
the Beast and the false prophet as him
and he
so supposedly the Beast or the false
prophet are individuals because it's not
referred to them it's referred to he or
him him
uh and the Beast was taken this now he's
quoting verse 20 and the Beast was taken
and with him
the false prophet that wrought the
Miracles before him
with which he deceived them that had
received the mark of the beast and them
that were worshiped His Image these both
were cast alive into a lake of fire
burning with Brimstone so that's the
first part of the question
um so you know
how do we understand that the false
prophet appears to be an individual
but
beasts are what's represent kingdoms so
is the false prophet and individual or
is the prophet a king a false prophet a
kingdom well Pastor Moore you know we
have in Prophecy
examples where
it's sometimes given to a beast the
title of a kingdom or the king the ruler
of such Kingdom so necessarily it it
when we talk about a beast it's not
necessarily has to be the physical
geographical location of a kingdom but
it also can mean its leader or its head
now I say that because for example in
the river in the prophecy of Daniel 2 we
have the elements that represented the
kingdoms and God speaks of the head of
gold to King Nebuchadnezzar as being the
one you know who was headed that metal
represented or is not necessarily that
he said Babylon represents that but you
represent that and I think that it can
be interchangeably used in in certain
degree now with that said in mind he
actually quotes verse 18 of chapter 13
to sort of set up himself into this
believe that the Beast represents a man
but really what it says there it's sort
of identifying something about that
Beast that is linked to uh to to men uh
we we hear actually and I would like to
go to Second Thessalonians 2 3 and 4
which speaks of what Paul interpreters
the men of sin that was to rule or to
come
uh you know and raise up in the latter
days verse 3 and 4 he says let not man
deceive you by any means for that day
shall not come speaking of the coming of
the Lord that day shall not come except
there come a falling away first and that
man of see me revealed the Son of
Perdition who opposed and exalted
himself above all that is called God or
that is worshiped so that he as God
seated in the temple of God showing
himself that he is God so he's speaking
their pole identifying this movement
that would have a man at his head at his
you know in in the control of this Beast
this power that will raise in the latter
days as the men of sin so I believe that
this verse is identifying that
individual that role that position of
authority within that system of of the
Beast which is the Catholic system
search and identifying the papacy the
pope as the head of that system so it's
not necessarily that it has to be one
individual specifically but is speaking
of the role and the position of
leadership of that man of sin or as the
Bible speaks of uh you know the man of
tradition certain Perdition of course
the head
has a body right and the body would be
the the group that he rules over because
the body rule the head rules over the
body correct uh you know it's
interesting in Bible prophecy yeah
beasts represent kingdoms
I think one of the problems that we have
um uh in answering this question that
this person has
is that he refers to the false prophet
it seems to be an individual doesn't say
false prophets says the false prophet
but the bottom line is that the false
prophet is a beast
in Revelation 13 verse 11 the false
prophet is identified as
the beast from the earth that races out
so the false prophet if the false
prophet is a beast that would mean that
it's a kingdom right because beasts
represent kingdoms like the lion the
bear the leopard and the non-descript
Beast they represent kingdoms of course
a succession of kings that rule over
that Kingdom uh and and so coming back
to Second Thessalonians 2 to show that
this is not a single individual
um
we're told in second Thessalonians 2
that the man of sin was already working
in Paul's day right but it's going to be
destroyed at the second coming exactly I
don't know anybody who's lived that long
it's not possible also yeah all Scholars
are agreed that the man of sin and the
Beast from the sea which represents the
papacy the same thing represents the
Antichrist power the anti-mantichrist
power
so if that's true then
um you know if it's a single individual
well that individual lived what 42 42
months symbolic and 1260 years no it's
impossible furthermore
in the Bible
uh when you have for example the priest
the king it doesn't refer to a single
individual it refers to a succession of
individuals right for example in Hebrews
9 verse 7 the expression the priest
refers to all of the succession of
priests in the Old Testament system in
first Samuel 88 and verse 11 it speaks
of the king clearly it's speaking about
the succession of kings and in second
Timothy 3 17 it uses the expression that
the man of God might be what it's
referring to all Christians and so the
fact that that the final final
Antichrist is called the man uh isn't
really significant another important
point is that you know this person who
asked this question I'm not going to
mention his name
um he also uh underlines the the word he
and him that is used in uh Revelation
chapter 19 and verses 19 and 20. but
when you go to the Greek language uh he
and him is not in masculine or feminine
it is neuter it's a neuter pronoun
which is that which is not a man a male
or female it's an it because a beast
isn't it so the false prophet is an it
in the sense that it's a kingdom it's
not a single person and so I believe
that when you look at you know the the
fact whether he and him is masculine or
is a neuter and as you look at the false
prophet actually being
uh not a person but being a beast which
represents kingdoms then uh you can
answer the question I think quite well
amen I believe so yeah you're right and
also this aspect Pastor that you
mentioned that
the identifying symbols in Revelation
it's really to for us to understand
without any doubt what that power or the
system that is speaking of really is so
we have to look at it as not you know it
doesn't go from a beast to a man
you know without realizing it's a symbol
it's a symbol that is establishing the
Bible to help us understand identify who
that Beast is and then the second part
of the question is furthermore only
physical beings or items could be burned
not kingdoms or nations so are we to
assume that the Lake of Fire in
Brimstone is also symbolic and what is
the effect of the fire and brimstone on
the Beast and false prophets thank you
in advance uh the the expression fire
and brimstone means that these powers
are going to be destroyed literally by
fire
uh you know it's kind of like Matthew
chapter 22 and verse 7 where because the
Jewish Nation rejected Christ it says
that uh the King was was angry and he
came and burnt their city right burned
Jerusalem well it's not talking only
about burning Jerusalem it's talking
about bringing the kingdom to an end of
course and uh and so I don't see any
contradiction there no and and I suppose
that ultimately in the Lake of Fire it's
not necessarily that the Earth
that the kingdom established is the one
that's going to be thrown into it
although the whole earth is going to be
uh you know basically purified by fire
so in a sense it is going to be but the
most important aspect is those that
participate are part of that system
those that believed in the
doctrines or the teachings of this
system are the ones that are going to be
burned we're along with the leadership
of course of the systems so it's the
leadership along with the kingdom yeah
that is consumed by the brightness of
Christ coming so there's no
contradiction it's not it's not uh uh
speaking that there's not going to be
literal fire there's going to be literal
fires but the little fire is going to
envelope the whole earth including
everybody who belong to that Kingdom and
every single thing the element that this
world has done every single uh thing
that humans have established these
kingdoms have established this beasts
have established are going to be burned
I mean does not mean nothing nothing old
everything is even new right is the
Bible says you know all right okay I
think we've answered that question the
best we can
um I hope that the answer has been
useful amen uh to the person who sent us
the question from Washington State
uh let's go to our next question
um do you as a Seventh-Day Adventist
consider yourself a Christian
well I I will say absolutely yes uh in
the sense that uh well there's no other
sense that we believe in the word of God
the whole inspiration of the word of God
we believe in Christ as the Son of God
who or a whole understanding of
scriptures all or gospel centers about
Christ so we accept we're certainly 100
Christians I think that this question
kind of comes maybe from the lack of
understanding of water
that our church teaches and sometimes
some people who have accused the church
from for being not really a church that
exalts Christ and there can be some
confusion from the individual that is
asking this question Pastor you know
um so so my question is
did Jesus teach the Sabbath
absolutely
did he teach the second coming he spoke
of that Seventh-day Adventist so Christ
was The Seventh-Day Adventist
absolutely he believed in those
doctrines he taught about them so yes in
fact Ellen White wrote this medical
Ministry page 49
Christ was a Seventh-Day Adventist to
all intents and purposes amen
so Christ was the seventh heaven now you
know
why was our church
named the Seventh Adventist Church I
think that's the important point because
Seventh-Day appeals to Creation
and Adventist appears has to do with the
end with the second coming
why in this period of History was it
important to name the church by that
designation well Pastor the fact is that
the world the Christian World prior to
the establishing this church had for the
most part
forgotten about the commandment to honor
the Creator on the seven day Sabbath
they had forgotten that that is the
Commandment that the Lord says remember
to keep remember to to honor there is an
element in as you mentioned that Christ
taught about the Sabbath that was made
for us it was created for the benefit of
humankind you know for the human beings
and to enjoy that communion with God the
presence with God and so the first
aspect why what we were named is to
remember or bring back to the minds of
people the importance of the Sabbath day
as a monument of creation as a memorial
to our believing Christ as the creator
of all things that we believe in
restoration also of of of you know of
the Plan of Salvation and then as you
mentioned the second part of the name
Adventist is reminding us that Christ
will be coming back as he promised he
will you know that he will come back for
his people for those that are looking
for his appearing and I believe this is
why the the name is inspired by the Lord
yeah there's no doubt whatsoever that um
the name was actually
um
divinely chosen for the church
uh you know uh The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church arose
in the midst of uh the origins of the
evolutionary theory
you know in fact the the book Origin of
Species was published in 1844.
wow that's right that's significant you
know the book by Charles Darwin right of
course um and so God raised up a
movement of course there was no
Seventh-day Adventist Church in 1844
right the name was adopted in 1860 but
God raised up a prophet
who would attract the minds of people to
the creator of heavens and the Earth not
by a process of evolution
but by a literal Creation in seven
literal days which was which was totally
unacceptable to the secular world at
that time right and even among some some
ministers it was taboo as well
and and so it's a rebuke to The
evolutionary theory because we believe
in a supernatural
fast beginning Evolution teaches a slow
and evolutionary theory of beginnings
and secondly it's a rebuke to the
Christian World absolutely because the
Christian World teaches that Sunday is
the day of rest
but the Bible teaches that the Sabbath
is the day of rest
it's also a rebuke to the secular world
because they don't believe that Jesus is
going to come again they they live as if
there's no communities and Christians
live as if there's no second coming of
Jesus you know they continue piling up
houses and and cars in adult toys and
money and 401ks and everything oblivious
to the fact that Jesus is coming soon
right and so basically the name
Seventh-day Adventist is a rebuke both
to the secular world and to the world of
the church because they it deals with
two doctrines a Divine Supernatural
beginning and a Divine Supernatural End
Amen I want to read a statement from by
Ellen White uh this is uh by the way I
would encourage everyone to read this
entire chapter it's found in volume one
of the testimonies 223 and 224 I'm just
going to read a small section the name
Seventh-day Adventist carries the true
features of our faith in front
and will convict the inquiring mind
like an arrow from the Lord's quiver
it will wound the transgressors of God's
law
and will lead to repentance toward God
and faith in our Lord Jesus Christ I was
shown that almost every fanatic who has
arisen who wishes to hide his sentiments
that he may lead others astray
claims to be the Church of God to belong
to the Church of God
such a name would at once excite
suspicion for it is employed to conceal
the most absurd errors
this name the name Church of God is too
indefinite for the remnant people of God
it would lead to the supposition that we
had a faith which we wished to cover up
and so basically the name Seventh-Day
Adventists as a rebuke to the secular
and to the sacred world if we can refer
to it that way is actually showing the
world what we believe
without hiding our identity under like
everybody claims Church of God Church of
Christ you know and they put some
names that you know for example I where
I first pastored in Chicago uh it was a
Spanish church it was called Iglesia
Pentecostal ARCA de Noe wow Pentecostal
Noah's Ark Church oh you know
what's what's the message there what's
distinctive about that yeah and so our
name
is in in harmony with Christ because
Christ was a Creator absolutely excuse
me yeah and Christ is the one who is
coming back excuse me right and so uh
they answered the question well The
Seventh-Day Adventists are Christians we
are Christians through and through
perhaps more Christians than anybody
else you know if we believe that as we
have mentioned the you know the Christ
as he the Creator crisis the second
coming so they leave that like I said
more Christians perhaps than those that
only hold on to the belief that he came
and died for us and understand that
there's a responsibility for us to
follow through when Christ is soon to
come back for his people even the devil
believes in trouble that Jesus came
that's another make him a Christian and
that he's in heaven yes and the Jesus is
coming again he knows all those things
that's right but it doesn't mean
salvation because he hasn't embraced
Christ absolutely absolutely okay let's
go to our next question
um do you have it there yes I have it
here Pastor it says uh good morning
pastors I have a question for you today
praise the Lord for his word and your
ministry John 20 22 please explain this
verse
I know the Holy Spirit was received in
Acts how do we reconcile these two
so he's looking forward to receiving an
answer to this question well let's read
the text you have the text yes I do
right here so the text in John 20 22
says
and when he said he had said this he
breathed on them and said unto them
receive ye the Holy Ghost
so that's the verse where Christ is
telling his disciples
to receive the Holy Spirit uh before I
you know I I say my fully Pastor answer
this question I would like to maybe sort
of set up this scenario on this question
here
first of all this happened right after
Christ
died I had risen up and gone to heaven
so the same day
he came that evening verse 8 19 actually
tells us the same day that he had
resurrected that same day at evening
been the first day of the week he says
the dog was shot and then he came unto
them and he appeared before them and
said to them peace be unto you and then
when he sees them he tells them
you know he he tells them
um or breeds unto them receive the Holy
Spirit
I believe that in certain degree you
know we have to realize that Christ was
speaking to them reminding them of the
promise that he had done to them just a
couple of days ago that he would send
the Holy Spirit now the Holy Spirit was
not sent at that time as we clearly know
as a matter of fact we can see in verse
24 that one of the Apostles one of the
12 Thomas was not even with them when he
Express this of you know receive the
Holy Spirit he was
reaffirming the I believe that Christ
was reaffirming them and expressing to
them the promise that when he will leave
as he mentioned once I leave I'll send
the Holy Spirit he was reminding them of
that promise that he would come to send
in the Holy Spirit and so the appearance
was for them to remember the prophecies
or the promise of Christ to reassure
them that they were not to be left alone
more than necessarily him giving them
the holy spirit in the moment because
they did not receive that and he
instructed them you have to wait until
the hospital comes upon you so Christ is
giving them a promise is sort of giving
them that assurance that as he's with
them as His I guess blowing into into
into their ex you know into the group
that was there he was going to be
certain to give him the Holy Spirit once
he was to go up to heaven yeah and you
there's another point so related
[Music]
is that
the Holy Spirit has a has a
pre-conversion function
and when we're baptized it has a
post-conversion function we're filled
with the spirit and so I like to call
the spirit that Jesus gave them in John
20 the emptying spirit
hmm because the the Holy Spirit it says
in John chapter 16 verse 8 and when he
has come he will convict the world of
sin and of righteousness and of judgment
right that's the convicting power of the
Holy Spirit what condition were the
disciples in at this point they'd just
been fighting about who's going to be
the greatest right that they have to be
emptied of self
so they could be filled with the spirit
of course you can't feel what's full
right that's true and there's another
fact you mentioned something very
important Pastor actually that is a very
good point that just you made me think
about this you know they were still in
this belief they still were doubting you
know who was you know that he
resurrected was he really you know
raised from the death so they were also
this they had this Spirit of unbelief in
some of them as a matter of fact Thomas
was not even there he didn't believe him
you know he was like I do not believe it
and so Christ had to come back later to
show him you know that he was truly
resurrected so as you mentioned the
spirit of conviction to bring them to
the to the to their minds that assurance
that you know Christ is restricted that
they needed to give up their their sins
you know the Holy Spirit had to cleanse
their heart that's right from from the
sin which they were unbelieving yes they
were fighting about who was going to be
the greatest they could not be filled
with the Holy Spirit bear with that
attitude and so Jesus gives them what I
call the the emptying Spirit empty to
have feel their conviction of sin their
need of Christ
and then on the day of Pentecost even
before the holy spirit is poured out it
says they were all of One Accord
because the spirit has had done his work
among them and then of course the Holy
Spirit was poured out and they were
filled with the Holy Spirit but there's
no contradiction between him giving the
spirit to them in the upper room after
the resurrection and being filled with
the Holy Spirit after they were gathered
together on the day of Pentecost I think
also even you know this is even more
beautiful to understand the connection
that Christ was doing by blowing the air
into them indicating or reminding them
that this Holy Spirit comes as you know
you don't see it but as the wind comes
you feel the effects of it amen yeah
well folks time flies when you're having
a good time
we trust that our answers today have
been useful to you may the Lord bless
you please send us your questions and we
hope to see you next time and I'd like
to know
[Music]
thank you